What's your background, Kevin? I can't
hear you.
>> Uh, I'm Annabaptist and uh
basically um I'm 15.
>> 15.
>> Handsome young man.
>> Thank you. And um basically
>> Filipino.
>> Do you have Filipino blood in you?
>> Yeah. Yeah, I'm Filipino.
>> You're penino, huh?
>> Yeah.
>> Are you full-blooded?
>> No, just half.
>> All right. What about the other half?
What are you? Um, white.
>> Say what? Your daddy found a peanut.
>> Yeah,
>> I know your dad was white.
>> I know. Because I know the white people,
they love them Filipino woman.
>> Yeah,
>> I'm just going to go ahead, brother.
Just go. Yeah.
>> And yeah, thank you. But um yeah, raised
Anabaptist and um when I was like 10 or
something, I got saved like fully. But
like just so recently
um I've been trying to develop this
relationship
further and when I I found out that it's
like really hard to live without sin cuz
like when you try to live without sin it
it gets really hard like the temptations
keep coming and stuff.
>> It's not going to stop man. Kevin, let
me let me get to the point because I
don't want you to confess too much in a
public forum. I don't want people to
know about it's public. It's why I say
always go to your priest, but since you
don't have a priest, your pastor, but
it's not going to stop. I'm 53 years
old, God willing, September. Every day I
struggle with lust. Every day I struggle
with food addiction. Every day I
struggle with anger, unforgiveness in my
heart. It ain't ending. That's why the
Bible says the Christian life is a life
of sacrifice and discipline.
So you think it's hard now, wait till
you get 50. So you have only one of two
choices. You either give in cuz you're
going to get tired and that ain't going
to do anything for you. Or like an
athlete, you're going to discipline
yourself, push yourself, sacrifice
yourself, resist your desires until you
finish the race. That means some days
will be better than others. Sunday is
like, "No, I'm not giving in. You don't
give in. Yay. It's like me. Today I
ain't eating that pizza slice. Yay, I
didn't eat it. And tomorrow I stuff my
fat face."
That's how it is. So, I'm going to give
you some scriptural
passages. You ready?
>> Yeah.
>> It's discipline. It's not going to be
easy. So, when you say it's not going to
get easier, so what I would do if I were
you, if you're burning because you're at
that age, you're burning with I know it.
You're brother, unless you are a monk,
you're burning with lust. Okay.
>> Yeah. What you're going to do is you're
going to pray hard. God, help you to
stay pure. And if you fail, just cry out
to God for mercy. He knows your
struggle. He knows it better than you.
And he's a God of compassion. And then
you're going to do what you can to be
that godly man who's able to start a
family. And pray God finds you a godly
wife and get married, man. 18, 19, 20.
You don't have to be wait till you be
30. Shoot. You want me there?
>> Yeah. But you got to make sure you're
ready for marriage and she's a godly
woman and you don't mess up. But here,
let me show you what the Bible says life
is, the Christian life.
>> I have a question about that though. Um,
>> is his name blotted out of the um
>> the book because he's living that life.
>> No, that's someone who has become so
hardened against God, does not
acknowledge his sin or her sin, and does
not resist that sin and ask God for
mercy. There's a difference between you
realizing it's sin, you realize it's
evil, you realize you don't want to do
it, you struggle with it, God will show
you mercy to someone who justifies it
and explains it away.
>> You understand the difference?
>> Yeah, I got that.
>> You don't justify sin. So, it's all
right. God understands. It's okay for me
to watch. It's okay for me to shack up.
No, no, you know it's sin. So, let's
say, God forbid you fall into porn. God,
I know it's sin. Lord, I don't want to
do this. I know it's sin. I don't want
to break your heart. Lord, please help
me. And God loves you. He's not going to
be, oh yeah, really. As long as you
acknowledge, as long as you don't
justify it, as long as you resist, and
even if you fail, God, I failed again.
Lord, please help me. Lord, have mercy
on me. Right? So,
>> yeah,
>> that's the difference in the attitude.
Not like here, Jerby, he knows gluttony
is a sin. He says, it's okay. there's
more to me to love. So, he just goes to
buffet after buffet and stuffs his fat
face because he justifies saying, "Well,
the bigger I am, the more there is to me
to love." See, that's sin right there.
You get my point?
>> Yeah.
>> All right. But anyway, now watch here
what the Christian life is. Matthew
16:24-26.
Then Jesus said to his disciples, "If
anyone wishes to come after me, let him
deny himself and take up his cross and
follow me." See, taking your cross is
something painful. When people got
crucified, it was painful, right? It was
one of the most painful things to do. So
Jesus telling you following me is not
easy. It's a life of discipline,
sacrifice, and pain. See it?
>> Yeah.
>> So you're struggling. Join the club. I
don't know if anyone here, if they're
honest, anyone here, if they're honest,
who will tell you they don't struggle?
Anyone here who's honest will tell you
they don't burn with lust or struggle
with other sins, whether it's food
addiction or anger.
Anyone here who's honest,
right?
This is a battle we all will face until
we die.
Whatever loses his life for my sake will
find a meaning. Don't live for your
pleasures. Live for me. So sacrifice.
But if it's a struggle and you succumb
not to worry, acknowledge it. Don't hide
it. Don't justify it. Cry out to me and
I'll show you mercy.
Okay. Now, let me give you some more
verses. You ready?
>> Yeah.
>> Here's the Christian life. Do you not
know that those who run in a race all
run, but only one receives the prize?
He's comparing Christianity to a
marathon that you run. How much time,
how many months, how many miles must you
run to be prepared to run a marathon or
a track race and win?
Long time, right?
>> Yeah.
>> A lot of running, a lot of dieting,
right?
A lot of sacrifice, right?
>> Yeah.
>> That's the Christian life. You're
running a marathon and you're running to
the finish line. That's heaven. That
means you got to keep running to get to
heaven. Well, that means that takes
effort. That takes exertion. That
requires discipline. And it may not feel
good at the moment, but the results are
good. Here, if I diet for six months and
hit weights, it's going to be hard, but
then I have a six-pack, not a keg, and I
have muscles, not love handles.
So the Christian life is a life of
discipline of training
run in the such a way that you may win.
Now everyone who competes in the games
exercise of self-control and all things.
See when you want to compete you got to
exercise self-control. I got to cut back
on my eating. I got to cut back on my
sleeping. I got to spend more time in
the gym. And the more time I spend the
greater the likelihood I'll win. See
self-control. No, I can't eat that
pizza. No, I can't sleep in. No, I can't
just watch TV. I got to go and run four
miles. I got to eat my broccoli and my
spinach cuz I'm Papey the Sailor Man.
You get it?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, it's discipline, isn't it?
>> It is.
>> They then do it. These people who do it
for the Olympic Games, they do it to
receive a corrupt crown. That crown is
going to fade away. But we do it to
receive an incorruptible crown because
when we finish the race, we will live
forever. Therefore, run in such a way as
not without aim. Run knowing that you're
running towards heaven. But that
requires doing certain exercises to get
to heaven. Prayer, fasting, Bible study,
obedience, charity, showing love,
getting to church. I box in such a way.
See, now he compares the Christian life
to boxing. How many rounds of sparring
must a professional boxer do? How many
miles must he run? How much jump rope
must he do? How many rounds on the bag
must he punch and focus before he can do
a 12 round professional fight?
That's months and months of sacrifice
and training, right?
>> Yeah.
>> That's the Christian life. So, what is
your training? prayer, fasting, Bible
study, obedience, loving your neighbor,
loving your brother, praying for others,
providing for those in need, getting to
church, keeping your eyes away from
things you shouldn't see, control.
That's your training, right? I box in
such a way as not beating the air, but I
discipline my body. See, it's
discipline. And make it my slave. I
don't let my body control me. I asked
the Holy Spirit to help me to control my
body so that after I preach others, I
myself will not be disqualified.
Meaning, you preach but you don't
practice and you end up in hell. God
forbid. May I I pray I'm not one of
those. Here's another example. 1 Timothy
4:8. For bodily training is only of a
little profit. Yeah. When you work out,
it benefits you, but you still die,
right?
>> Yeah.
But godliness, spiritual training is
profitable for all things since it not
only holds promise for the present life
but also for the life to come. How much
more spiritual training? Because even if
I work out and get a six-pack, I'm going
to die and my six-pack will deteriorate
when I'm in the grave. But when I do
spiritual training, I will live forever
finally. 2 Timothy 2:es 3-5. 2 Timothy
2:es 3:5 right here. Suffer hardship
with me. See, notice it's suffering.
It's going through hardship. As a good
soldier of Christ Jesus,
if you ever become a soldier, you're
going to have to go to boot camp, two
months of hell. And then if you're in
the battlefield, you're going to have to
be in rough terrain, always looking over
your shoulder. It is a life of hardship
and struggle and being alert. If you're
a soldier in the field, can you be
asleep?
>> No.
>> You got to be alert, right?
>> Yeah.
>> So, that's what Jesus is saying. You're
my soldier. Be alert cuz your enemy,
Satan's around. Don't be lazy and
slothful and he comes up and he kills
you. Be alert. Be aware. Get your
weapons ready. What's your weapons?
Prayer, fasting, Bible study, obedience,
fellowship, church, you name it. No
soldier in active service
entangles himself with the affairs of
everyday life. When you're in war, you
ain't got time for the petty things of
the world, right? Because you want to
survive. Correct.
>> Yeah.
>> So, you're in a spiritual war. You ain't
got time for the petty things of the
world. Like some kids will spend four
hours on Xbox. You're going to take
those four hours and study your Bible.
You're going to take those four hours
and pray. You're going to take your four
hours and go out and show Jesus to your
neighbor. If someone's hungry, you're
going to go feed them. You're going to
use your time and service,
okay?
So that he may please the one who
listens in a soldier. So you're going to
spend your time to please your general,
your commander-in-chief, Jesus Christ.
And also, if anyone competes as an
athlete, he is not crowned unless he
competes according to the rules. So
you're running a race, but you're going
to have to run according to rules of
Christ and finish and then he gives you
a crown. So welcome to the world of
Christianity, young man.
Thank you.